Unless a director’s number one priority
is performance, actors are lucky to get a
couple rehearsals before going to camera for
a role.
If an actor is given the luxury of time to
prepare and makes use of that time, there’s
a much better chance they’ll produce something
memorable.
Here are 10 Shocking Ways Actors Prepared
For Famous Roles
Heath Ledger in The Dark Knight
What some actors may have approached as a
classic comic book villain, Heath Ledger saw
as an opportunity to create something more.
To prepare for his role of the Joker in The
Dark Knight, Ledger secluded himself in a
hotel room for about six weeks to develop
the psychology and mannerisms of the maniacal
clown.
With a lot of prescription drugs and very
little sleep, he invented a deeply disturbing
yet mesmerizing character that silenced all
the naysayers.
It was a process that left a permanent mark
on the actor and on film history.
2.
Cast of Saving Private Ryan
All eight actors playing the soldiers chosen
to save Private Ryan had to attend an intensive
boot camp training that included a military
physical regiment and camping in soaking wet
conditions.
When they all voted to quit, their votes were
overruled by Tom Hanks, who played their commanding
officer.
As Private Ryan, Matt Damon didn’t have
to attend boot camp.
Spielberg hoped this would make the rest of
cast of resent him, and the cameras would
catch them hating Private Ryan.
3.
Mickey Rourke in Iron Man 2
Serious preparation can be a risky business,
and that risk doesn’t necessarily pay off
every time.
Mickey Rourke was very hands on with the development
of Iron Man 2’s Ivan Vanko.
Adopting a Slovakian accent, he learned most
of his lines in Russian, visited a prison
in Moscow, and paid for the character’s
gold tooth and pet bird out of his own pocket.
All interesting choices, but unfortunately
Rourke’s eccentric Whiplash didn’t gel
with Marvel’s more straightforward tone.
4.
Cast of One Flew Over The Cuckoo’s Nest
The actors became patients and the patients
became actors when filming 1975’s One Flew
Over The Cuckoo’s Nest.
To create a believable film about life in
a psychiatric hospital, director Milos Foreman
had the cast live in the Oregon State Hospital
and interact with actual patients who became
extras in the film.
Today it’s easy to recognize Danny Devito
and Christopher Lloyd, but apart from Jack
Nicholson the cast was all unknown at the
time, making it even harder to tell the performers
from the patients.
5.
Christian Bale in The Machinest
We’ve all heard of actors gaining or dropping
a few pounds for a role, but Christian Bale
took it to the extreme in 2004 when he dropped
63 pounds to play an insomniac losing his
mind in The Machinist.
To achieve this stickily figure, Bale had
a daily diet of a can of tuna, an apple, and
lots of cigarettes to curb his appetite.
This is the most weight anyone has ever lost
for a role, and if Bale had his way he would
have gone even further, but the producers
feared for his health.
As soon as filming wrapped, Bale was carbo
loading and helping his body bounce back for
his first outing as Batman the following year.
6.
Daniel Day Lewis in My Left Foot
No list of actors who went to to extremes
for their role would be complete without the
king of method, Daniel Day Lewis.
The film that first gained him this reputation
was My Left Foot, where he played a character
suffering from cerebral palsy.
Lewis reportedly broke two ribs during filming
to help maintain his hunched over position.
He also refused to leave his wheelchair between
takes and required help for every day activities
like eating and dressing himself, just like
his character would.
It clearly worked as the role would win Daniel
Day Lewis his first Oscar.
7.
Harrison Ford in The Fugitive
It’s been rumoured that Harrison Ford prepared
for his role as surgeon Richard Kimble in
The Fugitive by assisting in actual open heart
surgery.
Whether or not that’s true, Ford could have
used surgery himself when he damaged a ligament
in his leg while shooting.
Instead he opted to postpone treatment and
incorporate the limp into his performance.
8.
Halle Berry in Jungle Fever
Halle Berry’s first film role was not an
easy one.
Audiences were introduced to Berry as a crack
addict opposite Samuel L. Jackson in Spike
Lee’s Jungle Fever.
Lee originally thought Berry was too attractive
for people believe her in the role, so to
demonstrate her dedication, she didn’t shower
or bathe for the duration of her 10 days on
set.
Feeling dirty and uncomfortable helped Berry
get into character, but she had to apologize
to anyone who caught a whiff on those final
days of shooting.
9.
Robert De Niro in Taxi Driver
After being cast in Martin Scorsese’s Taxi
Driver, Robert De Niro got a cab license and
spent a month working 15 hour days as a cabbie
in New York City.
Even though he’d recently won an Oscar for
his work in The Godfather II, he was only
recognized once.
He also studied mental illness and PTSD suffered
by many Vietnam veterans at the time, helping
Travis Bickle emerge as a fully formed character
who would become one of cinema’s most iconic.
10 Jared Leto in Suicide Squad
With Heather Ledger’s posthumous Oscar winning
performance still fresh in everyone’s memory,
Jared Leto had to work extra hard to create
his own version of the Joker and separate
it from Ledger and Nicholson’s beloved interpretations.
On top of working on his lean and mean physique,
Leto was heavily involved in choosing the
look of the Joker and creeped other actors
out on set by never breaking character and
sending strange gifts inspired by their roles.
The jury is still out the results of Leto’s
process, but what we’ve seen so far has
made for a pretty sinister Clown Prince of
Crime.
Aspiring actors take note: it never hurts
to go that extra mile if you can.
There are endless ways to approach any role,
and the more creative you get, the more likely
you’ll deliver something special.
Did we miss any?
Let us know in the comments below and be sure
to subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this one.